this is probably like a really Boomer
thought but when I was a kid I would
have been one of those that showed up
for sure yeah for sure but
um now that I'm older and I see when you
have a big assembly like that regardless
of what it's for you're preventing
emergency services from accessing her
yeah and you're like you can't have that
like the reason that why the roads are
shaped the way they are is so emergency
service and get to people that need it
it's a very Boomer thought it is Boomer
because you're not thinking about you
haven't played God of War
[Music]
have you guys heard what about YouTube
and twitch personality Kai sinette that
was a bad thing bad thing that happens
oh New York is not happy he said he was
talking about New York no so this so he
decides to do a giveaway video which
tubers love to do it's a tuber thing to
do gets engagement right yeah and he's
going to give away shitloads of
PlayStation files and he's like hey
everybody I just want to put out this
little you know little social media
blast I'm giving away [__] loads of
PlayStation files right like six of them
like [__] whatever shitload is how much
how much do you think that is probably
10 plus it's like it's like 10 liters
yeah maybe a hundred a thousand a couple
kilograms a shitload of PlayStations
it's like 25 gallons yeah oh PlayStation
Plus right so like 30 consoles that's a
lot I think so we'll start with that so
he's 5.5 million followers on Instagram
he says I'm going to give away like
oodles and oodles and oodles on
Playstation 5's at 4pm so then crowds
start forming an hour before they were
like we're gonna go here like Union
Square okay yeah Union Square and it
starts a riot basically like people
start to lose their minds I've seen
videos of people jumping on people's
cars smashing I saw this cab driver I
feel so bad for him he's like I need to
work and then all these kids were
smashing their [__] Windows what the
[__] how did that turn into that
dude I'm telling
him he what he left
did he give any they were they were
climbing on like he had to drive out and
they were on his car when he drove out
it doesn't say If he if he got actually
got to give any away but I'll tell you
this I've seen a lot of pictures of this
incident I haven't seen many people
holding PlayStation 5.
I just saw like a bunch of kids on
cars smashing Windows all that [__] and
then like a lot of people like talking
about political [__] and I'm like what
the [__] is going and then it's like oh
it's just a giveaway that went bad I saw
a chick twerking on Lamppost I don't
know why
it's because there's a there was a train
a train station right there that was not
completed so there was all this
construction material oh and everybody
grabbed it yeah they grabbed like
shovels
that's why there's paint and [__]
everywhere that's the saddest part like
during um you know during the riots yeah
where like like all these cities were
burning up doing all this crazy [__] and
then so certain politicians have certain
stances some of them like you know like
Anarchy is never good chaos is never
good uh some of them are like oh like we
understand why people are really
emotionally hurt is the only way they
can be heard I always felt like if you
establish precedence then you kind of
make future other things and other
implications okay yeah and then New York
was one of the places where it's like oh
people have bad feelings so they're just
letting it out they're not they're
unheard people but now you have like
almost anything can turn into a riot a
riot giveaway Justified riots yeah but
as soon as Mass people get together like
let's say you you throw a EDC in a place
where they don't [__] around you know
they're gonna just shoot tear gas at
your ass
that EDC is not going to turn into a
right yeah you know but then if you go
to a place where you know they support
not support it but they're like they
they won't punish it they won't punish
it anything a [__] Santa's petting
zoo can turn into a right you know like
you get enough you get enough people
together and you get enough you don't
like mosh
you get another biscuit I just saw boats
with [__] it's mob mentality it just
morphs into something it could be
anything dude I just saw Rudolph and
goats with [__] Santa hats just
[__] tearing [__] up bro it's funny
because like you look at this [__] and
you're like grumbling about it but like
dude when I was 17 I would have been
hype as [__] yeah I would have been
doing bonehead [__] too honestly I
remember sucking random people in mosh
pits just because other people are
getting socks now I want to Sock someone
yeah I saw so many anchors recording
[__] and I was like damn what's up with
this mushroom haircut that everybody
likes doing these days is that like the
Edgar issue it's the it's the um the
Patrick Mahomes oh is it
so it's like a malt it's like a ball cut
yeah Big Time Mushroom up here do they
go do they go mullet I see that some
people mullet it I see they go it's
either mullet or the mushroom and it's
all curly they have to permit I kind of
thing and they got a little dangly
earrings they got pearls too a pearl
necklace the crazy thing that I I saw
about this is that they said that New
York has a department specifically to
sus uh social media accounts to
counteract these things from happening
so somebody's like basically a snitch
that's going yo they're saying they're
gonna meet up at Times Square like a
meet and greets they try to like uh
preemptively stop these things but they
didn't catch this because they don't
watch Twitch
but imagine like you're you're just a
social oh so he's not a YouTuber no he's
a twitch stream he's a twitch streamer
YouTuber he's a boy he's like he's like
the top but yeah these days these days
everyone's everything now oh it was
announced everywhere there's another
social media blast right
and then he's like I'm giving away
[__] tablespoons of PlayStation does
he do so he games yeah he games and the
people big time so were people like
where's the PlayStation you promised us
and then he start they started jumping
even at that point just that many teams
together in one spot it just gets wild
no matter what happens yeah even if like
because you first of all you can't give
everybody a PlayStation but it's not
even about that at that point it's just
people just get crazy I mean I don't
know what to say because I want to be
like look at these stupid ass unruly
teens but I was one of them that's what
I'm saying like you can't talk right I'd
show up for free PlayStation 5 are you
kidding me I'm not better than that but
I do feel like they should get punished
because that's how they learn their
lessons he's been arrested he he's been
arrested he didn't do anything wrong I
would say the crowd did [__] wrong but
it is wrong because it's illegal too you
can't you can't um administer an
assembly in a public place like that you
gotta get permits you can't just tell
everybody
should be
by the law by the law they should they
should be made an example of on site
yeah because it's pretty common for
influencers to do like meet and greets
at the park or whatever but I think he
doesn't but even those are technically
illegal but the the scale of it is he's
not being conscious of because if he's
got that many followers he knows like 30
000 people might pull up then that's
like that's [__] up yeah what was the
gameplay like just gonna throw ps5s into
the crowd like what was that but it's
just like having a house party if you
have a house party too many people show
up spills out in the street they do [__]
yeah you get arrested you should have a
10 minute 10 people maximum of quality
friends Bible studies Bible study what
game you think they all want to play
real bad
[Music]
they obviously want to play a game real
bad which one do you think it is yeah
[Applause]
let's get let's get to the Brass Texas
get to the point right yeah
um how would you guys punish these kids
because I feel like
they gotta learn a lesson
I take the controllers away
you get a PS5 but you can't play it no
HDMI for you sir because there were some
like young ass kids out there yup they
were saying that they were like young
ass like pre-teens that showed up did
they do any destruction yeah well I
don't know a lot smaller scale I'm sure
no idea maybe fines or something I don't
know something that hurts but it's not
too permanent yeah and then maybe like
really find the person that called the
assembly so this is probably like a
really Boomer thought but when I was a
kid I would have been one of those that
showed up for sure and I probably would
have showed up with a bunch of flammable
[__] just to make it even crazier yeah
for sure but have a pack yeah a bag full
of [__] fresh lint or whatever but
um now that I'm older and I've seen
things that happen I'm like when you
have a big assembly like that regardless
of what it's for like let's say there's
a lady that is trying to that has an
emergency
contraction yeah you're preventing
emergency services from accessing her so
you block infrastructure just because as
you get older you know more [__] happens
yeah yeah and you're like you can't have
that like the reason that why the roads
are shaped the way they are is so
emergency service and get to people that
need it it's a very Boomer thought it is
Boomer because you're not thinking about
you haven't played God of War have you
played the second one dude Christ so you
don't know what the context of what
these people are going through and the
controllers they have feedback
you'd be like this is so sick all right
[__] that [__] and that baby there's
too many people anyway I gotta get up on
this land person to work so I can maybe
get it I gotta get noticed you know so I
can play Horizons zero West one and two
maybe three yeah I think the the part
that makes this different is that it's
it's over you know like people are gonna
point this out and go yeah well when the
Stanley Cup happened everyone right when
this football team won everybody riding
but this is nothing it's just one dude
saying come down get a PS5 and the those
guys get permits so the Emergency
Services people are already in position
exactly they're ready
but then the fact that he this fool like
needs to understand his power like you
can do that anytime how old is the
streamer I don't know like maybe early
20s or some [__] so he's young too huh
maybe even younger than that I don't
even really know maybe she's doing a
soccer field or something what month was
he born in I think if you're I think if
you're over 20 I think if you're over 20
like if you're 25 and you're caught up
one of these you should definitely be
arrested you're too old for this [__]
bro
the braids twisted out yeah yeah I need
to know if you're a fanboy at 25 he's
21. 21. so that's what I mean so he's
young he's a silly boy you know he
doesn't know the right that's the hard
thing is like again like we would love
to be part of this [__] when we were
[__] that's true
it's hard to condemn yeah yeah someone
that's probably done less harm than you
right yeah because I'm just thinking
like dude I was [__] tagging all over
town and then I got in trouble for it
and I was [__] bricks about going to
juvie and I did it and I just got
probation and it and then that whole
process of continuously going to court
was scary but I didn't learn a lesson
because I ended up [__] joining again
doing worse [__] that's yeah like I
don't know if punishment actually works
the difference is that if it's harder I
think the difference in our day there
were fewer things that could make
something like that happen there's a ton
of dudes like him that could do that but
they're not I get what you mean there's
a shitload of people that have influence
over teens that they could be like yo
everybody come to [__] uh Foot Locker
at this mall it's like like that's crazy
that any time anybody can do that yeah
yeah so it's a choice you have to make
as a Imagine The Joy though of like I am
so excited to wake up this morning and
I'm gonna give away 270 fluid ounces of
places
he's stupid and then you do it and then
you got [__] JK news coming down in
your ass like the rest of the [__] yeah
[__] Boomer philosophies talking
about em it's like I'm hanging out with
my parents in this video it sucks
because there's probably a shitload of
good kids in this crowd too but they
could get [__] up I'll tell you it's
all the same if I was a if a 15 year old
Nick was a follower of this guy and he
was like I'm giving out ps5s on Union
Square the whole time 15 year old [__]
would be like this is a [__] scam I'm
not gonna go you're like he's not giving
away anything he ain't gonna give away
[__] but guarantee there's there's
probably a lot of kids there
care about the PS5 they just want to be
what shit's happening yeah you know what
I mean like and it makes sense like I
guess it's a pop and spot that's like
one of the [__] rubber neckers on the
freeway like the accidents over there
but this side is like oh dude that's
like gets jammed dude it's like when the
Powerball is like 1.5 billion or some
[__] you see everyone at the gas station
and you know everyone knows we're not
gonna win but everyone shows up and
they're buying the ticket they look over
their shoulder and they go worth the
shot hey what would you do huh yeah yeah
what are you gonna do with your 1.5
billion yeah I'd buy it perfectly gonna
do I buy a PlayStation 5.
[Music]
foreign